yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby uh
you look uh you getting yourself a
little magic mine draging a little bit
little bit Bud getting sleep not a ton
of sleep no not a ton of sleep an
eventful weekend and by eventful I mean
a nightmare yeah eventful week but but
our girls home our girl baby girls home
baby girls home yeah yep the picture you
sent me she she looked uh like she'd
been through a war with she had so get
some magic mine in you she's been
through the ringer let's get into it the
problem is cuz uh those hospitals sh the
Children's Hospital they're the best but
yeah you know she would finally fall
asleep but then they had they come in
run vitals maybe give her you know
medication or do this or this IV so it's
like every two hours they're constantly
just interrupting her sleep wow and then
me or Joe would be there so then we're
not sleeping either yeah talking eight
days of just like no I saw you I saw you
in the in line at the supermarket and uh
I was like I don't I think I I think
that's my friend Brandon shop yeah I
like people are like oh brenan's on
oamic no no no it's
stress it's
OIC no no no that's a that's a that's a
stressful time I feel like I well I feel
like
we're we're not in the belly of the
Beast
anymore uh yeah I mean yeah yeah you so
for now so 2024 has kicked me right in
the tits dude it's kicked you right in
the tits and lost my truck baby girl
issues wait but hold on uh the truck
isn't even in the same conversation oh
no no I'm just talking about no I'm just
talking about bad luck right I'm just
saying who gives a [__] about your truck
who gives a [__] about anything else
when it's your kid oh 100% I'm just
saying that like that sucks that that
sucks for me dude and that's how I
kicked off the Year yes and then God was
like oh hold on wait that was the appeti
we know oh dude that's the that's the
cherry on if you thought that was bad
check this out I'm going to make sure
your baby real can't
breathe you know so yeah it's been tough
man a lot of support though a lot of
support love you guys H out I see it
yeah thank you love you guys yeah it's
pretty cool I had a lot of people reach
out saying hey tell Brennan you know
praying for him there's a huge prayer
group I know uh lot of people send me
pictures of pray prayer groups stuff
there's a there's a couple friends of
mine who have a mass had a massive
prayer group grown it's pretty cool
pretty yeah I love it yeah I see at all
uh Rogan text me yep Rogan text me bunch
of other people but yeah I see it love
you guys yeah it was a tough time still
is but let's turn this thing to Comedy
um what else is going
on I was at the SHOT
show we've been doing podcast too long I
mean I was going to say what else You'
been doing you haven't do we've been the
I went to court oh you went to court oh
I didn't tell you this remember so you
remember when I saw that accident with
the those kids I helped out with the Dad
tried killing everybody yes dude I
didn't notice I got subpoena I was at
the that at the car shop two cops walk
in give me a subpoena I'm like what's
this for like you're a key witness in
this trial coming up I was like okay and
they're like uh you to be here tomorrow
and it was like right when right the
baby girl stuff's going down I'm like it
ain't happening man they like oh no you
have to otherwise we'll arrest you
that's oh you're mandated to go mated I
didn't know you had to be a witness
have to so you went and had that go the
guy there oh yeah to put on a suit go at
8:30 I don't know if you know how the
judicial system works dude I got there
at 8:30 I didn't
do [__] to about 3:30 that's right and
and I go I'm going to leave and she goes
you can but if we call her and you miss
it could be a worn out for your AR rest
that's how they get you no you'll stay
there in that really really what you'll
do is you'll stay in that Court area
which is super comfy with those benches
and criminals yeah because everyone's
going in out so I've never seen more
guys with tattoos on their face in my
life yeah there's just a b you know a
bunch of gang BS in there but I did you
know I watch a bunch of you know crime
docks and murder mystery stuff I did
feel like I was on Law and Order cuz I
would sit cuz I was bored so I'd sit in
in all the trials yeah so I loved it oh
I oh dude I loved it all oh wow I even
asked the lady I'm like hey I know I'm
not involved can I sit in there she's
like I don't see why not I literally
hours through all sorts of Trials like
guilty exciting right H pretty fun I dug
it do you know it is nerve-wracking when
you get like when it was finally my turn
when they call you up and the prosecutor
and the defense start questioning you
it's a little like yeah it's a little
stressful did you uh cuz you got you got
to have your p's and q's and that guy
that guy was clearly trying to kill his
family what's he saying claiming
insanity or something are you allow to
talk about it I don't know if I am but
he was trying to act like he was insane
during be careful about talking about
yeah it was weird yeah I'll just say
that it was weird the judge wasn't
having it the judge was not having it no
yeah um do you know what the number one
factor to antisocial behavior in males
is what is the number one factor
according to I guess criminologists and
you know people who study this sex no
okay friends social group no it's really
weird what is it it's it's simple
there's one fact number one what so the
number one contributing factor to
antisocial Behavior violent Behavior
criminal behavior mestation in young
males nope get molested no uh-uh it's
really weird I don't know man
fatherlessness oh yeah yeah that'll do
it fatherlessness when there's not a
male in the home and a responsible male
um boys don't learn how to regulate
their aggression so apparently women a
mother is good at teaching a a a child
to regulate their
emotions and men are in the house to
help boys regulate their aggression so
the boy starts hitting his his sister
and the father goes hey hey I'll I'll
you're going to get your ass kicked and
I don't know if those guys in courts had
dads or not but yeah you didn't ask hey
are you fatherless no just bring it back
have you ever been to court for have you
have you to be a witness or I was a jury
on a murder trial jury's different yeah
I was I was a juror you never had to
like sit up there when they question you
it's no dude it's just like Law and
Order yeah identical dude oh yeah I'm
glad I wore a suit because the other
side is trying to is trying to trip you
up oh yeah uhhuh yeah and and they
listen to the podcast when I did the
thing they have all of it dude oh yeah
oh yeah they've done that and you know I
I'm like well it's entertainment pod
because I would use words like this like
that you know when we talk you using
dramatic words I'm like this is insane
like you said insane so what did you
mean by Insane you're like no that's how
I oh wow oh that but then he started
poking the bear then I had to they'll
trip you up I had to like no they didn't
trip me up at home you then you lit him
up I had to light him up judge laughing
oh yeah I had the judge laughing yeah
yeah I'll tell you off here what about
what oh man I can't wait he's like you
said that's insane so would you say
that's insane and I was like it's insane
for someone with his athletic ability to
try and cross the street for me it's not
insane and I'm like the judge is like
that's good that's good now now um
they're smart too you got to make sure
make sure you can talk about this stuff
cuz if this hits the air this could
compromise your testimony I don't think
I'm not I'm not saying I me witness um
there was yeah there's bunch of
witnesses there okay um by a bunch I
mean four but
yeah uh [__] what was I going to say
that reminded me but my thing is I was
like well my baby girl's in the hospital
and they they do not care dude no don't
they put me first because I had to get
out of there to to get out of there but
they it doesn't matter for me for me I I
was uh at the time I had to sit on a two
gang bangers uh in a in a real in a gang
fun yeah two two gang sat on two gang no
no no these two gang gang guys from a
from a well-established gang they made a
u-turn came back and shot and they
showed the gun it was some crazy it was
like a 45 shot 45 slugs but it looked
like an assault rifle or some I don't
know kind of a pistol thing and then
another gun and they to kill this dude
and this one girl saw it and she was
terrified to testify and so I'm looking
at these gang gang members bangers gang
bangers why you so scared say bangers
and their whole and all the families and
all the other gang guys are there in the
well that's what people are worried
about if it's a gang affiliate case you
have to worry about intimidation so I
ask for a sidebar and I come up and I
say to the judge I go hey look I'm an
actor and I'm on a show that a lot of
people in these communities watch so I
don't really feel like if I come up with
a guilty plea and the defense goes you
you saying my client's guilty oh I'm not
saying guilty I'm just saying it goes
that direction she goes okay and the
judge looks at me the greatest judge
goes well you know what I never heard of
you and I never seen you so if they're
like me you're fine so go and I I didn't
get I didn't get off yeah they don't
care I was saves okay I was embarrassed
I was like I'm acting like a bigger star
than I am yeah but still those those
lawyers are beast man with their words
and [__] they're gangster man yeah we
found them guilty they went away for a
while I think 15 or 20 years that's it
and they and they made us it was
attempted murder yeah maybe more then
they made us um each say guilty they
wanted to hear each of us they went oh
can't just be no they want some they can
request that so all of us CU they're
hoping you'll be like oh I changed my
testimony oh wow so we're like guilty
guilty guilty and uh but the detectives
those those gang detectives that have
seen it all they're just up there that's
all they do this one woman was like yeah
I know yeah his name is he goes by pinky
he goes by you know crazy and you know
how people when you get a ticket or
whatever and they're like oh well
hopefully the cop doesn't show up to
court because they throw the ticket out
you know cops get paid double overtime
in when they go to court so they there's
incentive for them to show up so like
when I was in high school or when if you
had something in college go down like
hopefully the cop doesn't show up to the
court date then I get out of it no no
the cops they've made it so they're
incentivized to show up they get paid
double so you want the cop the cops are
always going to show up cuz they make
double the money yeah the more you know
the more you know but that whole legal
system I was like this is insane dude
just appeal appeal appeal this this this
and just drags on drags on drags on
everyone's getting paid the defendant
the everyone the judge the courthouse I
was like this is some [__] man the
whole legal system try the military
industrial complex I spent my time in in
Vegas doing a corporate gig for the SHOT
show which is the largest tactical
civilian convention you know in the
world and uh you want to talk forget
forget weapons manufacturers like you
want to talk about the money that's
involved in making from Scopes to oh oh
my God and it's pretty wild great people
but you know it's a very interesting
experience how about this for a little
something for you guys now do they vote
Biden there or uh no uh no but there's a
lot of uh a lot of conservatives but but
but how about this how about this yeah
how about this in I did a podcast with
Eric prince who is uh who owned
Blackwater a former Navy SEAL um and
Eric Prince has a very very intelligent
guy who was talking about how we should
have done the war in Afghanistan as an
example right let me let me give you an
example of how the US government works
that guy right there uh crossfitting
with him and my age and crushing me
crushing me but that makes sense because
he's Navy SEAL and a billionaire okay
and why why talk about how we should
have done something in Afghanistan it's
over well so it's like Detroit line
should have not because there's got to
be a way where the US government the
justice system so these things get so
bureaucratic so [__] I didn't know
this a fifth of our budget went to
getting oil to Afghanistan to run the
war effort okay a fifth so what we'd
have to do is we'd have to get our oil
from the Gulf States bring it through
the Mediterranean up to the Red Sea get
it piped in through Pakistan the patal
Bond's waiting with all their tolls so
it cost you so much money to get the
trucks there otherwise they'll blow them
up okay so now you got to get to
Afghanistan and now you got to truck in
all that oil it takes oh I don't know
what long a month whatever but it's also
a trillion dollars MH um we had oil
reserves in Afghanistan you know there's
oil wells in Afghan there is yeah I
didn't know that yeah but all the oil we
needed we could have we could have gone
right there and taken the oil do
exactly no it's just not how generals
think it's just not how they're like no
we'll get it from over here hey guys the
wells are right there they're right
there just take the cement cap off and
you could have literally powered the
entire country so that the people didn't
have to burn dung and plastic to stay
warm which they couldn't do anyway it's
[__] unbelievable unbelievable I'm
I'm outraged you should
be um so the next time we have a war
H did that fall in death
ears okay just tough you know yeah
okay did I get did I get out of our our
lane there I don't know what to do with
the oil dude you know it's like it's not
my it's but my pay grade okay I just
feel like we were piping it in when we
could have gotten it right there I know
it's annoying dude it's annoying it
started with trying say lot of waste a
lot of waste I have a question about the
jury thing yeah does everybody on the
jury have to be unanimous yeah yes one
vote oh yeah yes so if otherwise it's a
mistrial but if you stand up and say
guilty isn't that just an obvious thing
we all knew it was guilty no so you go
back when you go back you deliberate we
deliberated for a long time and it all
hinged on one decision that they made
the gang guys made to make a U-turn to
turn back around but you know you know
what's weird is like that when you take
that time to decide the deliberation
even I was thinking about this CU I was
sitting around from 8:00 a.m. to
freaking whatever it was 3:34 by the
time I took the stand yeah that long way
by the time you get there like I just
want what what's the easiest what just
get me out of here it's very interesting
so like the jury like think about it
like the OJ they're there for months
yeah and they're out of their house they
can't listen to radio they can't listen
to TV so they're like in this area where
they they're they have to be on that
schedule so think by the time it comes
you're like yeah whatever I was in but
now no [__] get out it's so interesting
you say that the human error is nuts so
so what what's [__] nuts about what
you just said is that they've done
studies on that and so uh the there's a
book called thinking fast and slow and
uh Conan who is a they won a Nobel Prize
for this they looked at parole boards in
Israel so when you're up for
parole if you came up for parole right
before lunch and they were hungry you're
good no you're not good they were like
they want to go through all of it they
were like he's guilty [__] it N I can't
I got to go eat man this I'm looking at
this thing they're irritated they're mad
and without a doubt your [__] entire
life hinged on whether they were hungry
or not is that crazy though I was
thinking the same thing some of the
other there's four other Witnesses some
were like At first like you know I'm
glad we're doing this is good for the
family but by the time 3:00 they're like
I don't give a [__] you I just want to
go home and in my head I'm like man if
this was like a major trial and thaten
affect so many people it's what it's
what happens it's [__] what happens
all the time our we put these guys away
based on one very critical decision they
made which was they we we saw where they
turned we said why they turn it this
light and not that light if they had
turned at that light we would have said
I can't prove that they did this but
they made a deliberate turn back think
about that it's going to I
mean you know I'm human I was like God
this taking forever man how can I get
with this quicker you know so one woman
was a stalwart in this trial that we had
she was like no I don't I don't think so
and I think what happened was she just
got tired and she went all right I I'll
just but but I mean we were right we
were right though we we we got through
to her cuz think about if you're on a
trial and whatever it's like going back
and forth and you're there for three
weeks you want to see your family and
you're the one not guilty and all you
need is one guilty it's like just say
guilty when we go home you're like all
right lawyers will tell you anything can
happen anything so you better not want
to you don't want to go to trial
anything the jury too they'll look to
see if there's any ties like on your
social media like if you're Pro let's
back in the day if you're Pro OJ Simpson
like no you can't do it he he he liked a
tweet from OJ Simpson he's already a fan
he's out so they look into everything oh
also if you if you're on a trial where
they're using where there was a gun used
okay if you were in the military if you
own guns you have to tell them that they
they want to know so as they're as
they're as they're choosing the jury the
defense wants to know what your
relationship to guns is are you super
anti-gun now now that's bias you know
it's pretty wild that's wild yeah
especially your life's hanging on it I
want to talk about five seon can we take
a little break and talk about CBD I need
to take well look you've had a stressful
time how you sleeping how you sleeping
not so well not great these days you
know I had a concussion recently and I
used C I used 5 CBD to help with my
brain tell tell me about it it's are
these are the five Daily Buzz gummies
yeah you just have to pay shipping and
handling you get a free $40 bottle if
you if you go with fighter and kid
exactly what I'm doing dude it's 2 to 5
milligrams of THC damn yep it's legal in
all 50 states third party lab tested so
I know it's made in the US OFA as well
right okay grown in USA um they got that
flavor Daily Buzz sour yep that's myor
fruity flavors and and stuff uh-huh yeah
take I take the gummy before right
before I go to bed suppos to help with
your brain when you have concussion CD
is good yep it's all good for Authority
certified so you know you're getting the
very best go to 5 cbd.com fighter get
your $40 bottle for free just pay
shipping and handling and uh give it a
shot that's 5 cbd.com fighter so it's 5
cbd.com
fighter oh Riley if you want Arium spark
plug Riley if you want aridium spark
plugs if you want wiper blades you got
all kinds of things at O'Reilly okay
dude I love O'Reilly I use them all the
time O'Reilly Auto Parts gets a $12
O'Reilly gift card after rebate when you
purchase four more select AC Delco spark
plugs maintain your performance and fuel
mileage with new spark plugs Brian even
though your car doesn't use them you can
also improve visibility with their new
wiper blades right now save 12 bucks on
a pair of rainx rugged XL wiper blades
plus get two time o Reward Points an
extra- large profile premium features
make rugged XL blades the right choice
for extreme weather driving and
durability also if you're like Brian you
need this professional Parts people will
even install your new wiper blad for
free I do need to do that that's fine
most Tesla drivers I don't learn how to
do that it's disgraceful yeah it's yeah
like if you blow a tire your girl's like
get out and fix I can't my God oh my God
yeah for spark plugs or wiper blades and
more save right now do- it right deals
in store at O'Reilly Auto Parts or go to
O'Reilly auto.com
mhm although there was a guy saying he
was from the hood and he said yeah yeah
yeah judicial system is pretty [__] up
but he said I don't know anybody just
doing life who is a good guy from my
neighborhood I don't know a goddamn Soul
yeah
so I mean you
know you ever hear the greatest uh
literary the difference between of
villain and a hero you hear how a great
writer or you know when you watch Marvel
movies or do you know what the criter
between between a li a a [__] hero
and a villain is I've heard one thing so
that what is it it was um if you're a
hero you live long enough till you
become the villain that's not bad but
there's the the the fundamental thing is
there's it happens to a kid the kid like
Batman has his parents killed in front
of him okay and the and the villain does
something the equivalent of drags a
knife across his face and just leaves
him a mark and says this will just to
remember me bye kid you know or
something like that
right the hero is the guy well the
villain is the guy who says the world
hurt me and now I'm going to hurt the
world okay the the hero is the one who
says the world hurt me and I'm going to
make sure the world never hurts anybody
like that again and it's an interesting
thing because that kid makes that choice
so is that kid that kid who makes that
choice is that kid naturally good and is
the other one naturally bad cuz that's a
decision you make as a young Batman one
yeah well do you think people are born
evil yes some people I think some people
are born um yeah I think some people are
born as absolutists where they see the
world in black and white and if you push
them or if they come if they see
something bad they go oh the [__] the
world right I think some some monsters
are created you know through you know
experiences stuff like that but I think
some people are just bad people and we
don't everyone wants to blame it on this
or that it's like yeah they might just
suck man they're born just shitty well
well I also think that you like for
example you and I we tend to be
naturally empathetic like I can't when I
see somebody who being like a dick for
the most part I'm like if you gave me a
good excuse his dad used to hit him you
know you and I are like a [__] all right
you know maybe you know it's like does
he really deserve to go to jail that
long we we have some personalities tend
to be more lenient more flexible more
whatever some people though like my
sister my sister is black and white
gangster yeah she's a gangster she's
like [__] you bad person good person
good people bad people I think the
world's a little more great than that
you been watching anything Buddy any new
um new love on the Spectrum not as good
as the first season yeah I've been
watching movies I watch bottoms you see
bottoms [__] hilarious it's about a
female Fight Club some good mov involve
gang some good there's some good movies
out there bottoms is such a stupid but
funny movie oh that's going to be a hard
note for me it's actually funny it's
actually funny stupid and then also uh
saltburn you might want to oh yeah
salurn love salurn God it's that's a
good movie
Jesus so I watched uh got Gotti on
Netflix got Gotti yeah three-part
documentary oh yeah this my problem if
you're balls deep and gotty like I am
it's nothing you don't I've seen all of
it before they just shuffled it
different all really they played the
tapes I've heard it yeah it's nothing
new like with Gotti there's nothing new
like if you're a gotti fan you've heard
all the the tapes of the FBI you've
heard there's nothing new he was he was
uh a massive narcissist yes and known
for that's what screwed him over well
also he wanted to be famous also he was
so dumb like he he literally had well he
literally had so they were all secret
society and their strength was that they
were Anonymous like they so when they
would be in a restaurant and they saw
one of their own they didn't say hi yeah
right it's all that [__] you didn't want
to be flashy no and and he so I know you
in a restaurant you coming with your
your girl or whatever I'm not looking at
you we might do this no he made a scene
he made a whole thing yeah he didn't
just make a scene you can see the
surveillance tapes he every [__]
Friday every mob family and boss had to
come and shake his hand and kiss his
ring outside of the ravenite they'd line
up yeah they'd see him like and they
were all like dude literally he's on the
front cover of time dude I mean in his
like that's what he wanted the worst a
narcissist got famous but he loved it he
called it our public our public loves us
and then a you're not supposed to sell
drugs start get selling drugs that's
what really [__] him got the FBI yeah
you know it was with him all the time as
Sam the bull always he the he ratted and
ended everything yeah he was well when
Gotti said you got to take the fall
Gotti was screwed already we're going do
that's what we're doing okay cool
there's a UFC fight night this weekend
but you got some time to the next
pay-per-view when's the next
pay-per-view chin in Anaheim Anaheim
right who fighting who fighting
anaheim's vcan hovsky I kind of want to
go
mhm ilot
torea I fought at Honda Center you know
who I fought
there hold on hold
on yes who big country no no God knows
that was The Ultimate Fighter finale
terrible take uh Gabriel Gonzaga on the
main card was Brock Lesnar Cain Vasquez
you fought probably the hardest leg
kicker at the time oh yeah yeah did he
get a piece them oh yeah he ate up the
leggies let me see the rest card go
don't go to my thing please was Daddy
checking we're staying on UFC not 298
was Daddy was Daddy checking them bad
boys this is a good fight card this is a
great fight card I mean Robert Whitaker
Paulo Costa this is very Jeff Neil
Machado did you see the thing
circulating on line chin of uh Ian Gary
and uh Jeff Neil fighting a bar but I
I'm pretty sure they it's not real
edited yeah know they thought it looked
like Ian Gary it's a different my
brother sent to me I was like that's not
Jeff Dil somebody else I don't I didn't
see it Henry sjo fighting morab
bashash who super tough yeah that's a
super tough fight for Henry Hernandez
Roman that's a good one that's like late
replacement Mackenzie dur I know that's
a bummer she lost her last one right
yeah
yeah yeah it's a it's a solid card for
sure
all right yeah I was talking to seudo
about that he was like I was like do you
feel like you have to prove anything
like you know you've kind of done
everything Pro yeah double CH and uh he
was like I just want to go out on top I
didn't like that I went I didn't like
that I got beat and that was that was
interesting that's what every fighter
says though you know no one want go off
a loss every every fighter that's tough
fight though for for sure yeah yeah Mor
Rob's a nightmare but Soo can do it for
sure yeah I again I would never bet
against that guy in any context he's Mor
Rob's tough tough is Rob very tough
fight chin thinks he's on EPO but
whatever no I don't his card his cardio
has to be the best of all time that's
what I'm saying like it's it's like
someone that's on EPO but it's natural
that's why it's so impressive
yeah yeah and then we're still waiting
for UFC 300 Main Event M tell me what
you'd rather seeb would you rather
announce uh DDP Hamot DDP p uh Izzy or
Conor
Chandler honestly honestly DDP
comat that's the most intriguing to me
you know yeah I think Chandler Chandler
um Connor Connor is not as exciting to
me I think that's what you're gonna get
though is Conor Chan really yeah uh and
then DDP Izzy I feel like Izzy's going
to take some more time off he's not he's
ready to go he's ready to go he can't
help himself he's got to come back
backing up the brings truck for him he's
ready to to
go um yeah I'm I'm um I'm I'm yeah I I I
definitely want to see I want to see I
want I guess I want to see if kamza I
want to see what kamza has I don't think
kza can fight in the states so I I threw
that one out there but I don't who knows
why there's EP in the room I said talked
about this on the shop show like Kat
fights once a year now but when they
were in Abu Dhabi fighting four times in
a month and no one wants to talk about
it he can't come to the state was it
something to do with his comments about
is room
no then that's mchf different guy no he
he also said some stuff no not like MCH
but he did by trust me the UFC's not
they're not worried about that's not it
but no oh there's something El ties to
the chesan leader yeah ham so we think
maybe the government yeah that's that's
what we're thinking I'm not sure though
that makes sense kadirov is cuz weird
that and he's you know he's boys with
him but they're not letting him travel
yikes so I doubt you get so he lives
like a king in ch but he lives in Sweden
yeah I don't know I have no clue but
he's very tight with him no he left
Sweden I thought he was in Sweden but
I'm not sure where he probably bounces
around but but what for every reason his
TI to the cing guy they're not he's just
not here
anymore yeah so then you get DDP Izzy
Connor and then we talked about this on
shop show um how ddps team reached out
to Izzy's team saying like hey are you
guys going to be ready for a fight for
UFC 300 or whatever around that time
period
and then they said yes so that's why he
called him out on when he won against
Strickland makes sense yeah so DDP know
not heating your advice oh taking his
time now
no
no interesting yeah I think that Izzy
fight's a tough fight for him yeah any
fight against Izzy is a tough fight
would that M would that be the one for
you though if like if it was DDP versus
St that would do it that would do it for
you cuz that UFC 300 is just not popping
I know it's so I thought I thought 300
was um Cheeto uh Ali no it's
299 when is that again that's March I
think early
March hold on let's 299 in Miami that's
the big boy card this is so far for
300 there's great names on there great
overall top to bottom it's all good
fights fun fights but nothing that yeah
exactly it's weird two 100 200 300
worthy it's going to knock your dick
down the back of your throat you know
Calvin Kar is fighting Alain at 45 I
would imagine FWE yeah huh that's a big
cut for Calvin Calvin's big guy wasn't
Calvin tough that's a I don't know how
Calvin Al going up yeah Kevin's always
Al really I gu he really did he fight
you think of Dan hooker no I've I've
just when you see Calvin ker I saw him
in Utah and he was so much thck I me
always really
big
wow that's a big cut for him man that's
but a lot of big names it's just like
the the you know it's solid I mean
eights everywhere but there's no tens on
there b nickel Cody
Brundage and B nickel's a humongous
favorite uh what are your thoughts on
Holly Holm Kayla Harrison love it yeah I
think uh Kayla Harrison is just I mean
[__] are they do they have very high
hopes for her she's never fought at 35
before that's a crazy cut for her she's
she walks around to 75 she said she'd
have cut off both legs to make 35 when
she started fighting yeah I don't know
how she's going to the the fight the
biggest story on that is can she make
the weight in perform that it's a great
there story lines all day with Kyla
Harris in
there
yeah this was uh$ 299 29 definitely
tastier exactly it's kind of crazy it's
just weird I wonder why they did that
for 299 you know why cuz maybe maybe
because Conor's going to save 300 and
they know if Conor's on there is going
to sell so they stack T9 if that happens
the F what they're G to do the exciting
fight also is Kevin Holland Michael
Paige that's gonna be yes that's such a
f that's such a fun fight chis blades
and ala's great Gilbert Burns JDM is
great our boy so many good match ups
here gamrat dos Angelos great yeah
yeah there there's a bunch of good
fights on there oh my
God but your favorite I'm sure is like
Dustin pory and Ben W St
deny uh I'm the most interested in that
fight yes
sh and uh Kevin Holland Michael pige
yeah there's so many fun fights on this
one do you would you ever I know you're
friends with both but shaa Mal Marin
Vera is there what do you if you had to
bet too early to call but
yeah too early to break it down you
know all right what do you got Jen want
start with that one ni yeah so this is a
developing story guys so six bodies were
found in the Mojave Desert some shot
some burned and they're saying they've
made multiple arrests but they still
don't know anything about it seems a
little so how they arrest them they
don't know anything about it well I
probably have surveillance bodies
it sounds a lot like uh cartel yeah yeah
I mean you know we're going to take you
out to the
desert um buddies were around two
vehicles based on large number of yellow
evidence also burned wow
yeah that leads me to think a little car
they not only killed but then set on
fire well at least they're dead when
they're set on fire there some earmarked
of Gangland style slangs yeah I mean
yeah what do you going do with that yeah
that that sounds like a classic Gangland
killing yeah in the desert in the mo
they know what's up if they're making a
res yeah well how many bodies are in the
Mojave Desert [__] God so this was not
so much of a current event but these
these guys that live in I think was it
Thailand or Indonesia or something or
Vietnam something like that they make
these cars that look like supercars yeah
but they actually form them from like
you know whatever just materials that
they have what and they're these cars
they look
legit let me see if it plays here no
audio though hold on I think this is
actually Vietnam so they build a
frame it looks like fiberglass right
yeah that's fiberglass yeah damn they do
it all by hand yes and they look that's
insane guys are so talented dude they
look like legit supercars yeah
wow damn that's nuts I know dude I mean
probably not the engines right
everything it's probably like lame as
[__] yeah they just but when they're
driving around no one's be twoes in it
hard to do no going to know no one's
going to know yeah but they build a
bunch of different typ you look good but
it's safe uh yeah so it's a net T that
is insane they can do that though yeah
dude it's all dude especially with
YouTube Talent people just know how to
like you know they see what's going on
they see like design patterns they can
just like figure it out if they're
really talented they can do it so don't
get hit that though right no I think you
have to worry about on the streets out
there yeah but the the real ones roll
they have roll bars and all that stuff
roll cages yeah or no um no no I mean
you can't get you you don't want to get
you know I love my favorite thing is
that sometimes on Instagram I'll get a a
a semi at going 35 miles hour hitting
different cars against a wall to see
which one flatten you'd be amazed the
ones that suck and the ones that
actually survive it it's crazy how dude
look at this this this is nut you guys
pulled this off yeah and the doors open
that same way too are super talented I
mean you could get them to do real you
know I mean they could actually do this
in America make Bank yes exactly they're
clearly stupid talented yeah very
talented and dude it it mimics almost
exactly what the car looks like in
interior and it's like that show is it
cake this is is it a car yeah is it cake
is crazy don't make a cake is it a car
and we they should I mean I'm sure
people with the eye for like Gearheads
could pick this thing apart but but are
they are they actually using the real
Parts though no well the light amaz I
know they're making themselves it's it's
it's mainly the body but look at this if
you saw this on the street you would
think it's an actual Ferrari that's like
a super car come on dude this one here
no you wouldn't no I mean because ber
has more of like a eye for it cuz he
what do you mean I know my [__] but
there's some things are off of about it
right but if I saw it I'd be like yeah
that's you know when the Chrysler 300s
they said looks like Royals Royce is
yeah until Royals Roy pulls up next to
it like let me see so is that a
Lamborghini or a Ferrari what is that
which one I don't know that top the top
one a Ferrar Ferrari yeah but dude come
on that looks let me see the real fer
cuz I can't tell that I can't exactly so
me and you
br yeah they're they're off but just you
know you know how when you get stuff
from Nordstrom's Rack or TJ Maxx and
like you get a Jordan logo and it just
be like a little thicker Jordan with
like his his shoe was off it's like that
or you'd buy like the polo shirt my mom
give me the TJ Maxx polo shirt and it
looked the horse and the rider looked a
little different that's what this you're
you have that eye do you know who was
like who was who was insane that way
Bradley Cooper which is why I became a
great director he would like see when we
were doing The Hangover he goes hey when
you come out have your belt untied like
you just took a piss it just just me
like little details like that I had a I
bought a flat screen it was back [__]
this is how long ago it was it was like
when flat screens were like you know
it's kind of a big flat screen and he
goes he goes I love it man he goes I
just take that little thing off and I go
yeah that what do you mean he goes a
little sticker yeah I go I didn't I
didn't see the sticker he goes the one
right there and the sticker was the same
color pretty much it was a little bit gr
see and I took it off and he goes yeah
now you go there you go and I was like
dude you're nuts some people are [__]
crazy about that stuff little details
yeah for me I wouldn't notice but I but
but it's good that you notice because
craftsmanship yeah like can I see a
regular Ferrari it'd be hard to see what
what is this called though BR this kind
of far I don't even know the name spider
uh say no it's definitely don't put
spider spider means it's a convertible
definitely not a
365 uh you could put for that one um the
law
Ferrari that it looks a little funky so
it's tough to tell could that might be a
l Ferrari yeah that's what it looks like
there you go there you go but you see
the actual one how it's not so fat and
like weird so it's a it's a work of art
oh law Ferrari yeah yeah look at that
thing hold on now put their I do know
now I'm not making fun of what they do
what they do is [__] nuts but I'm
just saying compared to the actual
Italian made FW Ferrari but what they're
doing is nuts is it is it cake is it a
car that could be a
show I mean it what they do is
Incredible without a doubt unreal but
I'm just saying if you lived in Vietnam
you would have one of those and we'd be
like dude you're spending a lot of money
on a body of a
car you see it's just some things are
just a tat off but damn it's so damn
ridiculous close though it is yeah it's
just I know I know what you mean though
see how the exhaust is off on the back
there the far left see how the left is
higher than the right yes the little
things like that's an issue you see you
see how the lights see see the the depth
with uh see how there's so much
clearance on the back light you know
what isue it's a very expensive toy
versus the real thing and they took so
much time to do these C oh dude it's no
I'm not making fun what they do is notos
they're just you know but yeah that
that's definitely see the gap between
the back lights like all that there's a
lot yeah yeah this one's like a little
falling down sadle so when you but now
but now the locals there they're like
holy [__] dude you guys are from outer
space it's all about getting laid oh my
gosh I wonder how it sounds too like
it's horrible like a lawnmower engine
yeah it's [__] Toyota engine right
right Bugatti
Ferrari um so Vince McMahon has been in
the news yeah it was big WWE weekend
guys the only guy who's had a worse 2024
than me is Vince
McMahon [__] hit the fan for Vince so
Vince is in the news right now he
immediately resigned from the WWE uh
text messages have come out between him
and an employee that is accusing him of
sex
trafficking um between him and some
other wrestlers and these messages are
intense
okay uh I love it that's you don't read
this this get kicked off YouTube you
just can't get let me finish reading it
D rock
[Laughter]
hard well all
right
um yeah he said keep don't read it
screen keep going next one oh he's gone
oh there's a lot oh so supposedly he was
supposed to man three big flag keep
reading mhm how do they know for a fact
that this is I don't know that's oh they
know oh they
know I
mean that's this is the embarrassment
wild the embarrassment level for Vince
is got to
be keep going but he's just a freak keep
going all right enough yeah is already
crazy no sucks for the showby keep going
yeah he's a freak so this is him right
yeah can can you go back for a sec
because go back to the next one the
first one yeah cuz I want to just say
something hold on
uh which part Bri this part above
okay I'm just trying to see if this
happened yes I oh no it happened so he
was telling her that he was showing all
his crew what she
wants you understand and she
was yeah when I see stuff like this I
don't know dude like it's
like yeah if you look into the story
there's Parts where there's like
defecating and like passing her around
to other WWE employees and but then this
part here right so I know what's real
what's true one he says what he wants
her to do he goes can you imagine and
then right here the girl says like give
me another week baby give me another
week baby I'll be ready I'm feeling more
like myself it's not great but it's
getting better tell them soon like what
is that okay I don't know it sounds like
she's down for the count maybe who knows
SS one small who knows she was getting
paid to be his fantasy yeah maybe I
don't know and he was a Voyer she was a
she was an employee she was an employee
and months ago when this first came out
apparently he had said I'll pay you $3
million just let it go but he only PA
came to him was like
he and he only gave her a million so but
he's had previous stuff right yeah like
he had and then he stepped down I think
as president but he's still on the board
still running it and then now this is
probably the last fully resigned yeah
the C yeah I don't yeah this all after
that5 billion Netflix Netflix deal I'll
tell you what's interesting remember TK
which owns UFC and w WWE uh UFC's
contracts up end of 2024 so they're
going to start negotiating soon so don't
be surprised if you see UFC follow suit
like they always do follow WWE to
Netflix because Netflix wants live
sports that's what they want so I'll be
surprised if they jump ship from ESPN
which is a sinking ship and go to uh
ESPN how old is Vince he's got to be 80
I
think this is this is
nuts hold on is it nut 78 is it got that
big and powerful on steroids and stuff
in the WWE I mean uh you know I go like
this
huh I agree with you no it's not nuts
it's like M okay part for the course but
um I want to know what her what is she
accusing him of because she was getting
paid and she was a voluntary participant
in this in her 30s right so I'm so
confused as to what
who my my forced them
to I mean this this sounds like it's got
it sounds like he was asked to coer to
having sex with wrestling stars and
other WWE Executives along with more LD
action o yeah I guess yeah but coerced
her what you're an adult and you could
have said no and you got paid for it
unless unless he was like like she lose
her I don't no it's tough yeah but he
also [__] on her head even still even
still he what he [__] on her head no
yeah he did where uh go up I tried
to uh where was it was it on the top top
uh no here it goes um Jane Grant claimed
wrestling Mogul corer into having sex
with wrestling stars and other WWE
Executives along with more lured
allegations that include McMahon
defecating on her head during a thre
Simon using sex toys that he named after
wrestlers okay well now he sh on her
head she should to now he needs to go he
needs to go to he needs real he needs to
go to therapy and probably be in a
hospital for the [__] insane because
no can you imagine though if like if you
having a threesome like if you me and J
were having a thre and you just no and
then you just go
to dude you're [__] up the V what the
[__] y dude you shouldn't here it's
going to R what I mean
and you're going to keep going I Bri
just think about it if you [__] in here
the party the party is over who in the
world it's going to smell who can keep
going no no one's thought about this
it's going to smell to high heaven this
guy hey this a to room this is not sex
this is depravity on the level I can't
even believe well no what how's it even
work human feces are you you you
squatted over over Dad [__] you think
like how about hepatitis and all the
back I mean no it's just a smell forget
about all that you're getting old dude
I'm talking about the smell of human
[__] while you have an erection can I
get a hazmat suit and a [__] and and
a and a SCUBA tank with a with a filter
because this is [__] horrifying but
the whole thing's over you think it's a
Vibe K hey how about this if you I go V
if you for hard it's over if your friend
if you're like both doing this thing and
your friend
goes you're going hey dude hey wa dude a
hard far to [__] up The Vibes dude Tak a
[__] in another room it's a problem but
but think about you're in Vince's
Mansion he shits there it's like dude
who's going to clean this the we got to
burn the room I'm I'm actually I'm
actually you know what I am flabbergast
think about the logistics of human [__]
well it's outrageous the mattress is
screwed the bad is but I mean how how
the smell of [__] on your like this is a
guy who couldn't get off until he got
crazy depraved this is an insane human
being this is a guy who is such an
extremist this is part of what makes
people like this so successful is they
have a dark side I think that's so
[__]
up like what are you doing dude how are
you like this girl didn't think this was
sexy what was going on with her what was
going on with him what's going on with
everybody invol were there other people
here there's a threesome threesome
threesome they he took a [__] while
there's other people that was your
employee who needed that job so badly
who was like oh God oh God I get fired f
f how you I'm G throw up dude throw up
I'm GNA run away as I'm gonna I don't
know what I would how are there not text
I've heard being like dude last night
was crazy you [__] all over me like I'm
never coming back also pay me $10
million I'm GNA tell everybody you [__]
all over me well I mean pay me all the
money well hold on hold on I have a
question Brenan
what do you what do you need for me to
[__] on your head there's no I I no
there's
no who are the other two wrestlers who
are like yeah dude take that [__] I
don't get it all it seems weird is there
a possibility she's making that up no
yeah is there a possibility because he's
an old man he was going crazy and he
went and and when he came he went oh
[__] and he lost control is it was an
accident it had to have been an accident
on her head though well yeah why he
what's he doing up top well I know what
he's
doing yeah so he's getting whatever and
he's getting he's receiving oral
satisfaction he loses it and probably
because he's old [__] how does landine
on the head though because if you're
standing over her but her no she have to
be behind you then who knows dude but
she might doing the only thing I can
explain is I don't know what to call it
the old what Brandon the old the way by
the way he had to pay 14 he's had to pay
$14.6 million to several women who
accuse him of sexual misconduct from way
back so that's a lot of money a dude a
freak
man I just I don't get it I mean I don't
get the whole Logistics with poop in the
room I just I'm
fascinated Sor if you're laying down
flat and he's standing over you he's is
in your M and someone is from this ANG
right there you go that's an easy that
it's like right on your eye J you SE
show uh double dare yeah I think I'm I'm
going to give Vince
McMahon saying that that was probably an
old guy accident I don't think so I
think he's a complete freaka did on
purpose and put a Cleveland steamer
right down the face there just no I
can't even I can't handle that I have
children in this world oh and there's a
78-year-old man putting a [__] troan
[__] helmet down somebody's
face yes there are people there are
people people are crazy it's like if you
these these sex prosecutor ERS and these
FBI guys they'll be like whoever don't
don't think anybody that you've met I
don't care how nice they are how much
they give to charity don't think that
these people aren't complete [__] nut
cases they're serial killers people who
are into that they can be the most
they're the last person you think
sometimes what else you I'm holding my
stomach I'm actually holding my body I'm
just so interested uh how the how's it
work I don't look at these look at these
[__] uh so you guys been a bunch of
protesters l all these but these don't
work cuz they you can't get to them on
Alisa it's covered this does nothing
they're such asshol did they realize
that's not the they're not actually
spraying them Mona Lisa it's covered cuz
they know there's more on Fanatics look
at these [__] Fanatics they see see
how it's behind glass I would I would
they they' be in jail for a long time
yeah n their life suck if you're doing
that that's the penalty that's so dumb
it's such Fanatics we have to save we
have to save the Earth from global
warming so I'm going to destroy a
masterpiece I don't get it but they
think by us talking about it they're
from the environmental movement
repost but you're talking about them oh
they sprayed pumpkin soup which is just
spray off that's what it is though we
talk about it they're they make the new
that's what they want and you even gave
their company a shout out yeah but they
can go [__] themselves yeah but that's
all they want be you did it they won I
see and it wanted to draw attention to
unsustainable food production and hunger
in France really it's so dumb
they're so dumb man like that are so
[__] dumb but they don't hurt the
painting and it you know just gets them
talked about this
one is that one yeah no next
one come on man you come
on let's just do this one here all right
uh Joe Rogan apparently recently was
speaking out on like this German Farmers
issue where there was a blockade and
he's getting a little bit of a flack
from it you guys watch this episode no
who was it with it doesn't say I don't
know who is with but German Farmers like
made headlines for setting up like
tractor convoys and he's coming out
calling the German government out and
saying like you guys got bigger problems
to get after he's saying let be
Farmers yeah I don't know what he was M
the ger Firs really made headlines for
set up attractor Convoy blockades across
the Europe European nation protest of
government tax Tikes subsidies cuts for
Al hold on let's get this here ah yeah I
was you know and then I don't know
piggybacking off that Joe Rogan's most
watched episode was with Elon Musk and
he was smoking weed on the episode but
now elon's saying he's been drug tested
a ton since then of course of course and
as a result the FDA is now thinking of
defining marijuana as a lower risk
drug H because because of Elon yeah you
would think he's an amazing guy so for
elon's on some different stuff now you
tired huh bud no I Smoke I Drank I mean
I I smoked I slept too much I slept 10
hours last night oh wow yeah I've got 10
hours in I mean that's that's annoying I
was like how do I sleep that much um did
you can we talk about the games did you
watch them otherwise I'm not going to
talk about watch the games you did y
what' you think um I thought that uh
there was no way that the 49ers were
going to come back the way they did 24
to7 bummer for I felt bad for I'm a ners
fan because of mcaffry but I felt I like
Detroit I felt bad for what do you think
was it they played really bad in the
first really bad and then some of Dan
Campbell's calls you know with the
fourth downs and then also the receiver
not catching the ball a shitty
cornerback like Stan Fran's good man and
then plus you give him opportunity with
the fourth downs and you know not
kicking field goals like San Fran's
going to bite you ass MH but it but
people get mad at Dan Campbell but it's
like have you not been watching all year
this is what got him to the dance you
thought he was going to change right is
this what he does like the the argument
should be is like some of the passes
that um homeboy threw what's the
quarterback's name for Detroit uh gof
you know he made some bad throws he
missed a lot of guys that's not Dan
Campbell's fault and then the receiver
dropping that's not his fault you know
they they could have won they they
literally lost the game God what do you
think s do um I think bad bad play
calling you know when you lose by three
and you have two opportunities when
you're fourth and two or three or
whatever and you don't get the field
goal the fourth and one and it'll run
for it on the goal line now remember
he's not the F coordinator I get it he
could V to it I guess
but I see I will say that their back
field like none of those receivers
looked open that was what blew my mind I
was like dude they couldn't get open and
go had a lot of time in some cases but
lot of people also underestimate Brock
they don't think he's a mobile
quarterback but he he is he Bal out he's
a mobile and you know he's not a system
quarterback um no really bummed me out
was the Ravens game the Ravens like the
Ravens but again the chief's backfield
was unbelievable they they they shut
down two secondaries prob I me best in
the NFL but also Lamar Jackson hate to
say it it's not a winner but I don't
blame him I blame immaturity there were
three or four different how about the
interception in a triple coverage who do
you blame there whose fault is that how
many excuses we going to make for him he
got but then Brock pie wins and then no
one brings it up it's how great Lamar is
well Lamar Jackson got him to the dance
I mean almost he always gets him to
dance always almost he's almost Jackson
he's never won in the playoffs never
wins I just think there's a lot of
immaturity on that team like the flowers
called the taunting called the unne oh
the penalties was n you cost yourself 15
yards that that play when he did the
taunting the 40 it should have been a 45
Yard Baltimore was so on disciplined I
don't much blame him for get losing the
ball in the end zone cuz he he was
trying to reach and get it over and he
that was just an amazing play by uh
whatever his name is on on Kansas City
but that must have been tougher Kansas
City's interesting because for the first
time they have like a legit defense like
four or five all Pros on defense and now
the offense they don't need Patrick
Mahomes to throw for 400 yards and ball
out now Travis Kelce can just do okay
and they still win cuz the defense is so
good that Travis Kelce Mahomes
combination is I mean oh Pacho I mean
Beast he's a beast I think the ners beat
him you do I don't remember that game
but why why no I'm saying I think the
nighers beat him in the Super Bowl oh
you think so yeah if they're healthy
yeah yeah yeah what what what is ners
just had a bad the the first half they
just didn't you see what they can do
when they're firing all defense they say
that the ners are the most talented team
yeah top to bottom I don't know all over
yeah but you know people like Stephen A
Smith is now calling Mahomes the goat
which is think go you could make that AR
over Brady you can make that argument
come on four out of the five four out of
five Super Bowls I mean whatever he does
he never misses like that guy the best
I've ever seen he doesn't miss you don't
think he's more like the things he does
is more impressive than Tom Brady not
numbers wise obviously Tom play a lot
longer but as far as like what he's
capable of like if you could pick let's
say they're both rookies yeah if you had
to bank on one guy yeah I going with
Brady coming a lot doesn't have Brady
doesn't have the mobility he doesn't
have that he does crazy [__] you never
saw Brady go falling down throwing the
ball he just does he runs he he like
Brady was great in the pocket he could
set back he was so accurate he's a total
winner he had a great line for most of
his you know he had a lot of protection
I think well Mahomes has a yeah ridic
Mahomes Mahomes can Mahomes has all of
that he never seems to miss he throws
Right On Target no matter what the
stakes his team's stacked though te Tom
BR didn't have his I mean team is stack
but here's the here's the larger
question as a as a novice Watcher of
football it does seem that so let's just
take passing in the pocket you could
make the argument that Mahomes is at
least as good as Brady yes or no yeah
okay so now you have that so you have
that then you'd have this um but Mahomes
is more is more mobile Mahomes does
crazier athletic things when he's being
taken down he whatever it might be he
didn't have to do that though yeah he
didn't have to do that and he couldn't
do that so to your point if you had to
choose who you wanted on your team the
question
becomes what are we talk with two
minutes left I'm thinking Brady all day
he doesn't lose yeah but either does it
seems mes so the question is if you if
you had to choose you know Mahomes is
more athletic more mobile can throw the
same in the pocket just as much a win as
much a winner well so the other thing is
the other the other part is he does seem
to be able to make decisions in
split-second timing without throwing
interceptions right is this conversation
racist am I wrong what do you mean
that's always the knock like that's the
thing that analysts do is when it's like
a a non-white guy it's like really
athletic it's the white guy like
decision making but but well that's a
good question but I would say like
that's not on Lamar it's like oh he can
just run he can't pass so you won't see
him run as much because he wants to beat
that narrative when it's like dude just
win the [__] game you can do it all
he's a great player larger question is
when a quarterback like
Brady Brady set a tone like you were
talking about of discipline and of of
Team he's a general so he's a general so
he he that's Dak Prescott's problem not
not a general there you go so so Brady's
Brady's presence created a culture of
winning and excellence and you could
make the argument so did Jordan right
and then and then does mahom have the
same clearly they're four out of five
but it's also their head coach is a big
deal yes and Andy Reed's a beast Andy
Reed's a beast he's a legend Travis
Kelce and remember before that they had
freaking the cheetah yeah so do you
think who's your who do you think son is
gonna win the Super Bowl that's a tough
one I got the Chiefs you got the Chiefs
well I just think momentum and I just
think Travis Kelce and I just think
somehow they get it done I don't know
I'm taking Niners you are yeah Mahomes
has been the starter for six years right
he's been to six AFC championship games
it's insane this will be his fourth
Super Bowl it's insane Brock P's Been To
None it's insane but the quarterback to
me would be momes the team itself would
go to the ners yeah they're yeah agree
ners have so many weapons on offense BOS
is on right
now I just beast but what you'll see in
the Super Bowl what I love about the
Super Bowl is it probably won't be the
CMC show there's going to be these
underlying kids that have not there's
always someone that comes out of the
Woodworks K KD didn't have a big game
stat wise but his blocking it was insane
really I can't see I don't see those
things danger people in no football can
see all these things I don't see his
blocking was I mean yeah two things
matter in playoff and Super Bowl time
it's the running game and your defense
defense yeah it's it's got to be a
physical game they both have great
defenses man physicality though the ners
who's going to be able to cover
Kelsey who's going to be who in the back
field is going to be able to do that
who's got the
size they have guys I mean it's the ners
for God's sakes I don't know yeah they
have a bunch of all
Pros be a close game we'll see man let
see what the over under is I bet it's
Niners by three
four
[Music]
h what are the odds
that's what we're looking at looking him
up right now here we
go the number settled on 1.5 on Sunday
evening meanwhile the total is 47 but it
moved to 47.5 so that's the over under
the 49ers are a two-point favorite
according
to that's fair they Molly whopped him
during the regular season right I don't
even remember that far back I think they
did they beat him up what else you got
Jen okay we can't play this trailer but
we we want to play it for you guys cuz
Conor McGregor and Jake Gyllenhaal they
doing the the remake of roadh house and
dude we've both seen it though so you
don't need to play it never mind I was
watching cuz the audience can't hear it
either so it's like but it was it was do
with Connor I let me see the you're an
act so you know I'm impressed with
Connor in general wait you saw it or you
didn't I saw it I'll watch it again no
let's not fast forward to the Conor yeah
just go to Conor well it's only it's
only what is it two minutes it's two
minutes and 30 seconds I'm kind of happy
with his body that's why he's
jacked guys okay BR what do you think
say this right now say it Oscar
worthy I'm G say it right now mhm single
greatest movie ever made what did you
say said single greatest movie ever made
I think it's gonna be good uh Doug Lyman
who's done a bunch of action movies uh
I'll uh I'll watch it I'm definitely
going to watch it I was there and
somebody goes I was watching the game
with a bunch of early guys one of the
guys goes you know you make Road House
gay you cast Jake Gyllenhaal I love Jake
gyllen I love that guy disagree with
that I to me too I was like that guy's
great sounds like that guy might be gay
who I was G to say I was like sounds
like you're just jealous of his amazing
body no I love J I'll watch it's on
Amazon too it's not in the theaters so
that makes it even easier wait what I
thought Jake did a uh didn't Jake do a
an MMA show but I guess he's playing a
movie he did an MMA movie I guess but
this is not it no he did boxer
no but he also did an MMA movie this
this is the he becomes an MMA fighter he
literally is in the UFC in this movie oh
that's the story it's an ex UFC fighter
that's a tough one and he finds himself
out there and and then Connor's great he
did really well right like yeah as far
as acting great have you seen the
original Road House with the sway it's
it's my generation okay have I seen it I
lived it oh I Liv it I I'll check it
out I love J Jake Jal doesn't miss it's
on Prime so I'll definitely check it out
so it's not hitting the the movie
theaters just straight it up that's
interesting what but a lot a ton of
movies are doing that ton of movies are
doing that
now wow all right all right I think
that's it guys Louisville Comedy Club
March one and two oh by the way I'm
gonna be oh [__] I get that uh in
Bakersfield me and Sam tripy doing a
[__] gig and then and then that would
be the H anyway it's sometime and then
Christ I know I got to find out and then
I'm the rec room in Long
Beach check it up I got to put it up
there and then Bricktown Comedy Club
March 8 and N holy [__] dude what a mess
yeah bad news all right kids that's it
love you